you need to work on yourself if you just
try to be pampered and if you're trying
to be soft and if you're trying to be
the victim and all of you're not going
to go anywhere we need to get stronger
we need to get tougher we need to not be
afraid of failure we got to face
adversity adversity breeds character we
have to be willing to go through
hardship through suffering don't shy
away from any of that because it just
makes you stronger and I think today lot
of times our youth is so IND kind of oh
let's make him feel good oh no let's be
more sensitive well I totally agree with
you to be sensitive about things but I
mean there's also a sweet spot when
someone says well today I just need to
sleep in it's said yeah you
don't need to sleep in this country was
not built on sleeping in so let's get up
in the morning and let's get on that
bike and let's do some exercise and
let's just get going boom boom boom
let's get going let's start building